a unique structure a revolutionary
wonder of Technology that's how the
British celebrated the completion of the
tower bridge more than 120 years ago the
iconic landmark has spanned the Thames
river in the heart of London since 1894
I was born in London I grew up in London
so is the symbol of our city the more
that you work it and more you realize
what an extraordinary place it is you
know from going up to the high-level
walkways where we're at 33 and a half
metres above the road going right down
to the base the very base of the
foundations where you're below the river
level Richard Smith knows what he's
talking about
since 2012 he's been guiding tourists
around what may be Europe's most famous
bridge the fairytale towers are the
ultimate monument to Victorian
neo-gothic style
but the bridge which draws almost a
million tourists a year also has some
modern elements
[Music]
glass balls were put in in 2014 to
heighten the visitor experience here at
our bridge each of these panels weighs
over half a ton and they are eight
centimeters thick it's extremely strong
it can have up to 150 people on here
five elephants at a time we've never
managed to get five elephants in the
lift though sadly so we can't prove that
the Tower Bridge was built at the end of
the 19th century to relieve the
jam-packed streets of London which had
the most traffic in the world at the
time construction took eight years
architect Horace Jones based his design
strictly on the style of the famous
Tower of London it wasn't until the
silver coronation Jubilee of Queen
Elizabeth the second in 1977 that the
steel parts were painted Britain's
national colors red white and blue
today the 244 meter bascule and
suspension bridge is still one of the
city's most important traffic arteries
every day 40,000 people have to pass
through the bottom leg
but even at rush hour ships always have
the right-of-way there are no exceptions
[Music]
back in 1997 the then president of
United States Bill Clinton and his wife
Hillary were having dinner without Prime
Minister Tony Blair and his wife in a
restaurant very close by they stayed a
little longer than they scheduled to and
they left in four vehicles the first
three vehicles went through the barriers
the blue gates closed
signifying a bridge leaving Bill Clinton
stuck in South London on his own with
just a bodyguard and a rather anxious
driver the tower bridges majestic
appearance has made it one of London's
most frequently photographed landmarks
[Music]
many euro max viewers have immortalized
themselves in pictures taken in front of
the bridge
[Music]
this is a magical place and I'm really
happy to see from real something that
always is like an echo in the world but
especially because I think there is a
very ancient energy in this part of the
city it's a lot prettier than I thought
okay
lot prettier than we imagined that's
amazing I like it's such a nice view of
London and like you can take everything
in
I really like the how old all this stuff
is we're from the States so all of our
monuments don't date back this far so we
find that really interesting many
visitors don't know that the bridges
70,000 tons hours are part of the
attraction a few times a year the huge
empty space is inside them are used for
chamber concerts
if you ever come through the arches of
the main towers of tower bridge beneath
you is a drop of about 30 meters which
takes you almost down to the to the
river level
it's an extraordinary space you are
amazing acoustics and it is a very very
very unique place to go for a concert
now you won't be surprised to know that
those sold out very very quickly and if
you can't get tickets for the chamber
concerts never fear you can always
listen to one of the many street
musicians against scenery that's unique
in the world Adam